hello everyone good morning america is
coming to terms with another mass
shooting six people were shot dead and
dozens injured when a gunman on a roof
with a high-powered rifle opened fire on
an independence day parade police have
arrested a 22 year old named robert e
cremo
according to the gun violence archive
this is the latest of
311 mass shootings in the u.s
so far this year
mark stone is standing by for us in
chicago um hi mark yet another mass
shooting in the u.s
morning kay yes it is so depressing to
be reporting once again
from another mass shooting this time on
the north shore of chicago here in a a
pretty affluent neighborhood chicago is
a place known to have its problem with
guns with gangs but this was something
different this was a neighborhood
families gathering together on july the
4th
to remember and celebrate independence
day
captured in the space of just a few
moments america at its patriotic best
and its bloody worst
an extraordinary volley of gunfire
filmed from multiple angles on the
phones of those who were at this
independence day parade to have fun
some run others for a moment think the
noise is part of the show
quickly realize this is yet another mass
shooting and this time it is their
neighborhood
the gunman had been firing from a
rooftop picking off his fellow americans
young and elderly
there was a young child there that
people i was doing a little cpr until
the paramedics got there and he looked
horribly injured i'm not sure exactly
the injury but i mean people were doing
anything they could it was just crazy
and i just heard i just remember hearing
people
screaming and running
it took nearly eight hours for a manhunt
to end with this the arrest of a man
authorities say is a person of interest
robert e cremo the third known as bobby
is just 22. a search of his name online
has revealed a social media footprint
that will be vital for investigators
an amateur rapper with a fascination for
guns
videos that appear to depict mass murder
it suggests a dark troubled personality
five people were confirmed to have died
at the scene
it's a slight moment of silence in
washington a moment of silence
the president's july 4th address was
hastily changed to reflect the news
you all heard what happened
you all heard what happened today
but each day we're reminded
there's nothing guaranteed about our
democracy
nothing guaranteed about our way of life
we have to fight for it
defend it and earn it
by voting
all down this road the chairs the flags
the bits and pieces of an independence
day parade left behind
as people ran for cover this is a
community which began the day ready for
that all-american ritual of july the
fourth and it ended the day numb
and again with so many questions that
gun debate will go on and on
how did he get his weapon and where did
he get it could all this have been
prevented
schools churches supermarkets now a
community parade
another community shattered
just so depressing k as i said and when
we arrived here uh this evening in fact
having come from a a another
independence day parade in washington dc
these are things events that happen in
communities right across this country we
arrived at this one so similar to the
one that we were at and
it was just eerie awful as you saw um
empty
and all the paraphernalia of a family a
day out left there
in terms of the investigation will the
police have a person of interest as they
are describing him in custody he's a
local man you saw a little bit of his uh
social media presence
there in my report it will be a center
of their investigation what we don't yet
know of course is did he legally own the
weapon what sort of weapon was it how
did he get hold of it key questions that
the investigators will want to answer
and the american public not least here
in this community will want answers to
and fast okay uh mark thank you thanks a
lot
premier league footballer has been
arrested in north london on suspicion of
rape the man who's in his twenties and
can't be named for legal reasons has
been questioned over an alleged rape
which happened last month according to
the police he's being held in custody
following his arrest
airline passengers are being urged to be
cautious when buying travel insurance
ahead of what's predicted to be
a summer of disruption new research from
consumer group which reveals that four
in ten policies offer no protection for
cancellations caused by strikes ashna is
at bristol airport for us this morning
which is exactly what so many people who
are traveling don't want to hear isn't
it
you're right kay considering the amount
of pressure the travel industry has been
under if you're not worried about if
your bag's going to make it whether your
flight's going ahead now there are
concerns about potential summer of
disruption when it comes to strike
action and what that could mean for
passengers as you mentioned their
consumer group which has found that 40
of travel insurance policies do not
cover you when it comes to flights being
cancelled because of strike action they
assessed 199 policies and they found
that 78 of those did not cover
passengers there is we know widespread
disruption across the aviation industry
so this will only add to concern only
yesterday easyjet's chief operating
officer many of those flights of course
operating here from bristol airport uh
resigned after uh thousands of easyjet
flights have been axed last minute in
particular but we know that it's not
just that airline it's a number of them
whether it's london gatwick london
heathrow bristol but we know also abroad
internationally amsterdam
airport has also had to cancel a number
of flights we know that those last
minute cancellations are only going to
get worse particularly this week the
government has given carriers till
friday to make last minute changes to
their schedules before facing a
potential penalty but this news about
travel insurance i mean we used to take
it out aren't we when it comes to
preparing for the pandemic when it comes
to strike action you won't be covered by
40 of those policies
okay for now thank you going to catwick
airport in just a short while to bring
you the very latest from there as well
105 000 british airways passenger seats
are going to be cancelled because they
cannot cope with the demand what does
that mean for you uh we'll be speaking
to simon colder who is the travel editor
of the independent very shortly meantime
let's turn to ukraine where president
putin has declared victory in the
eastern province of luhansk and is now
setting his sights on donetsk what does
that mean for the people of ukraine and
indeed the president sally standing by
for us in kiev sally good morning the
latest from where you are please
yeah it certainly feels like the war is
entering a new phase okay uh that
victory in luhansk uh for russia that
one of two provinces that make up the
donbass region which they
are intent on taking control of that's
really the biggest victory for russia in
this war since uh mario poll fell in may
and many towns and cities that many
people will not have heard of before the
last few months have become common
parlance well uh expect to learn a few
more new names in the coming days and
weeks
as russian forces set their sights on
don yet that's the other region that
makes up the donbass where ukraine
maintains a lot of control there
certainly in in the major cities and
sloviansk and krematorsk are two cities
that you will no doubt hear a lot more
about in the coming days slobians has
already been hit pretty hard in the last
few days by russian forces
as they try to now look at moving their
offensive into that region but i should
say that ukrainian forces have had a lot
more time to build up their defense
positions and reinforcements there
they're confident that they will be able
to defend themselves much more there
than they managed to uh in luhansk but
certainly one thing that they need is
they need more weapons more artillery
and more rockets specifically they're
being completely outgunned by russian
forces they're not superior to them in
terms of manpower but they certainly
need much more artillery in turn in
terms of trying to turn this tide okay
sally thank you
well our special correspondent alex
crawford reports from the frontline town
of mourinka and krasnodar jorvika
they know the rest of the donbas is next
on the russian target list
we're the first british journalist to
get a look at the foreign supplied heavy
artillery they hope will turn the war
for them
and they remain optimistic despite their
recent losses with this message to the
russians
it's not for long the commander says
we'll kick you out and get it all back
the loss of one half of the donbass is
tough but they're not giving up they
can't
this heavy artillery system is highly
accurate and highly mobile they've been
provided to ukraine by multiple
countries this one's a caesar and it
comes from france but they are still
heavily outnumbered and outgunned by
russian stocks and that's why they're
crying out for many more
the russians are already pushing deeper
into eastern ukraine
this is the ukrainian's most effective
way of fighting back
the donbass battlefield has seen the
most intense fighting of the year so far
since the russian leader unilaterally
declared the two regions independent
but russia wants all of the donbass and
it doesn't look like much is going to
stop them
this is what a howitzer can do here it
obliterates a russian tank but this
modern weaponry's arrived late and maybe
not in enough time to save the donbass
you can watch his watch alex's full
report on our website news.sky.com
hundreds of people have been rescued
overnight thousands more residents in
around sydney are affected by flooding
days of torrential rain on australia's
east coast have led to dams overflowing
and rivers bursting their banks let's
get the ladies should we from uh windsor
in new south wales nicole standing by
for us again this morning nicole you
were telling us yesterday this is the
third fourth time that families have had
to put up with this in what 18 months
that's right and there could be even
more to come
uh authorities had been hoping that the
rain would ease off over the over the
next few days but it seems that it's
going to continue more wild weather is
expected and that's why we'll keep
seeing scenes like this i mean this is
the scale of the flooding here and
around sydney right now just miles of
flood water this should be a major road
connecting two towns but we just took a
boat
out there and houses are underwater a
sports field you really can't see
anything it's just like a massive lake
as you said people here are exhausted
they're tired they're fed up from
constant flooding three and four floods
some houses have gone underwater
multiple times and that's because for
the last couple of years australia has
been under a la nina weather event and
that has brought these torrential rains
and sort of wild weather to the east
coast of australia viewers might
remember a few months ago big rains and
flooding up in lismore where ten
thousand people are still homeless in
this flood right now nineteen thousand
houses are without power
fifty thousand people have been affected
uh they've been told to either evacuate
from their homes or to get their plans
in place so that when emergency crews
come in and tell them to leave that
they'll be ready so it's a very serious
situation uh people are really upset
we've seen emergency crews out and about
trying to rescue those who haven't
heeded the warning to get out while they
can
they say that many people have actually
become complacent a little earlier today
we also saw crews out trying to rescue
some of the wildlife here we saw a joey
and a kangaroo in fact
come out on a boat just here
very typical australian thing i suppose
you would say but what isn't typical is
this rain
and it is winter here so we would expect
to see some but not to the extent that
where that we've had over the last few
days okay for now thanks very much
indeed thanks a lot
i want to look at what the papers are
doing for you this morning as well very
much uh reflecting on what's happening
with uh boris johnson um shall we start
with the daily mirror the mirror leads
with news the pm didn't know about
previous allegations against chris
pincher before appointing him as deputy
chief whip
looking at the guardian for you now
saying two major unions are calling for
parliament to act to stop what they call
the seemingly endless allegations of
sexual misconduct by mps
looking at the telegraph for you it says
labour leader sakir stama is facing a
party revolt of his own over his
decision not to take the uk back into
the eu if he becomes prime minister
the metro leads with fuel prize protests
which affects several uk motorways daily
mail reports the home secretary has
ordered police to crack down on any
future such protests
also the lead story on the front of
today's times which has the headline get
tough with petrol protesters and the sun
has news of the arrest of an unnamed
premier league footballer over
allegations
of rape
deputy prime minister's with us now good
morning thank you for joining us on the
program um tori sleaze
how long have you personally known chris
pincher was an alleged sex pest
well that's a very generic term what's
the specific question um uh i've
obviously seen the most recent
uh
reports he's stepped down as a minister
he's had the whip withdrawn i think the
reports are very serious they deserve to
be independently investigated that's
what will now happen under the
parliamentary grievance process i think
we need to respect that i think the
integrity of the system is very
important for me the most important
thing is that
anyone who's got a complaint of this
kind of severity must feel confident and
comfortable in coming forward what
exactly did you know about his behavior
well
there's a list as long as my arm yeah
but
that's true so but there's always
reports and rumors swirling around
westminster it's that kind of place you
know that and
lots of these things
don't materialize
and and actually having worked with
chris pincher um i always found him on
the whole
very professional but as there's a
reporter about a complaint that was made
at the foreign office i'm sure you're uh
poised to ask me about that and we dealt
with that in the most rigorous and
robust way
i'll do the questions you do the answers
2019 he was working for you were you
completely comfortable
with uh being his boss when these sort
of allegations were being leveled
against him well just to be clear
because that's a specific question i
gave you a very clear answer there was a
complaint made by someone that worked
with him about inappropriate behaviour i
swiftly agreed with the permanent
secretary to simon mcdonald at the time
that that ought to be reviewed under the
civil services auspices to make sure it
was done without fear or favor it came
back and
did not recommend
formal disciplinary action and it should
be said that the individual that made
the complaint did not want that um i
spoke to chris pincher about the
inappropriate behaviour made it clear in
no uncertain terms it should uh desist
it must never be repeated so did the
permanent secretary for additional
assurance because i take this so
seriously i also referred it to the
cabinet office the cabinet office
proprietary and ethics team which also
looked at it for example to see whether
actions warranted on the ministerial
code they didn't they they agreed that
it didn't warrant that so
although there was a complaint made
about
inappropriate behavior it did not
trigger the disciplinary action either
the civil service level or the cabinet
office level in relation to the code of
conduct
so i uh not only followed it to the
strict letter i went beyond that and
sought the assurance why because i think
it's so important that people that make
complaints fuel and can have the
confidence to come forward so it's the
proprietary and ethics team's fault that
he keeps that he continues on with this
list of
inappropriate behavior at the very least
i
don't think anyone could say i was
blaming them um anyone what i wanted to
make sure is that there was proper
assurance and integrity around the
process because that's so important
there's a load of you know what
westminster's like there's a whole rumor
mill but when you get a specific
complaint important that that's handled
rigorously robustly and fairly it again
i also made the point that the
individual concerned wanted to continue
working
with
chris pincher at the time and did not
want formal action taken
what about the uh foreign minister the
prime minister's now wife who made um
her comments in writing in 2017 when she
worked at troy central office
well i i can't speak to that i don't
know about that but of course that was
under the previous prime minister
yeah but she the prime minister must
have known you suggest are you
suggesting that carrie then um simmons
now johnson never spoke to her prime
minister husband about the behavior of
this man no that wasn't what i was
suggesting i don't know the facts of it
what i was saying is that the
reappointment of chris pincher back in
2017
following uh complaints to be made about
him at the time followed a process an
independent process conducted by a qc
which did not
uphold the claims made against him and
his reappointment as a minister at that
time was obviously under the previous
government and the previous prime
minister those are the facts as i know
them okay talk to me about what downing
street we're telling a junior minister
bless him yesterday will quince this is
what he said to us on the show yesterday
it's going to be in this screen
i spoke with number 10 both yesterday
and today and i asked them firmly and
clearly for an answer on this and i've
been given categorical assurance that
the prime minister was not aware of any
serious uh specific allegation with
regards to uh the former deputy chief
whitman
is that true
yeah i don't think the the look
i don't think the prime minister is
aware of any substantiated complaints to
the extent that they would trigger a
formal mechanism and as i said and
there's a distinction between the rumor
mill of westminster and complaints that
either result in a formal process
uh or a formal sanction yeah but the
prime minister we heard from downing
street what three hours later saying
that four hours later the prime minister
was aware of allegations that were
either resolved or did not progress to a
formal complaint as a lawyer i mean can
you tell me the difference between those
two points yeah the difference is a
complaint that is made that is of uh
where there's the uh evidence and it's
of the severity where former dis formal
either disciplinary action is taken
which is something which would happen in
all professional walks of life in or in
addition uh triggers mechanisms for
example under ministerial code of
conduct and so the allegations
that we're talking about had not reached
that level and that's precisely what i
the account i think i've just given you
fairly and squarely about what happened
in october of 2019. so just to clarify
not aware of specific allegations is
what the minister sat there and said he
checked with number 10 they said to say
not aware of specific allegations four
hours later aware of allegations that
were resolved or did not progress to a
formal complaint that is dancing on the
head of a pin
i don't think it is i think we'll uh
from what i just uh understood talked
about specific and serious allegations
and i think there's a distinction
between something which is either not of
the severity or isn't resolved
informally and something which clearly
does trigger a formal disciplinary
action or formal sanction and i think
most people would understand that that
is a fair and reasonable distinction to
draw but there's a pattern of behavior
isn't there 2012 2013 2017 2019
september 2019 2021 october 2021
december 2021 june 2022
is that really somebody who is an
appropriate person to be
laying down the law as deputy chief whip
well you've just read out a list of
dates
and i don't know what each one referred
to but all i can say is where there's
been a credible complaint made they've
been followed up whether it was uh by me
in the foreign office or in 2017 there
was a qc that conducted uh the process i
think that's right there is a rumor mill
in westminster and i think it's
important both for the confidence of
victims but also fairness that you have
independent processes and i think that's
absolutely i mean what you're
complaining about is that we've been too
loyally and done it too much i'll
complain
i'm trying to get down to the bottom of
what well
but i think it is important to be
absolutely uh rigorous and and
scrupulously go by the book
um and of course in relation to chris
pincher's appointment as deputy chief
whip the cabinet office proprietor
ethics team did not raise an objection
to that appointment we rely on these
independent processes because they're
capable of commanding the trust of those
with which we work and that is the
crucial thing in all this case i wonder
where the bar is though how high are we
setting how low are we setting this bar
well i don't think it's right that just
because there's uh rumor and gossip
someone loses their job i do think of
course not no i do think it is right
that when there are a complaint is made
it is properly investigated and then you
know is it serious enough is it credible
enough to warrant formal action whether
it's disciplinary under the ministerial
code i think that's the right bar to set
okay so when you were his boss yeah um
you were completely happy with his
behavior you say that you pulled him to
one side on one occasion yeah why was
that
because of the you know the complaint
that was made
what was the complaint i i just because
i'm respecting the confidentiality of
the processes and those involved i don't
think it's right for me to go into that
i know why you ask the question what i
would just say is i spoke to in no
uncertain terms i have to say
and this is no excuse this is no
mitigation but if you're asking me my
sense is that chris princher was
actually an exceptional minister and
very well regarded and it's interesting
and this sometimes is the case with
inappropriate behavior it's interesting
that the complainant that came forward
did not want formal action taken now
that can be for all sorts exactly
i'm agreeing with you as we know and
that is why i totally agree and that is
why that relationship between ministers
and the civil servants who do such a
fabulous job for us needs to be
protected and that is precisely why i
went and asked the cabinet office to
look at it again to check that the
judgment of the civil service was right
but
i don't know what to say to you because
because no action was taken against him
you say there wasn't enough evidence
because uh someone didn't want to press
that further for whatever reason they
might be anxious they might have been
concerned always the reason you have an
independent process is also to check
regardless of what the complainant says
whether it is of a severity that would
warrant disciplinary action but it looks
as though it went on and on and on even
to the extent where last week last
middle of last week
he was groping allegedly two men at the
carlton club people watching what was
going on well the minute that complaint
was made
he
he resigned himself he i don't think he
had any choice and the whip was removed
pending a formal investigation under the
grievance and complaints procedure of
the house of commons that is the correct
way to handle that allegation what did
the pm actually know do you think
i'm sure you must have talked about at
which point in time i i talk i've talked
him through um
in recent days what happened in um uh
2019 um
my my sense is but again um
i i can't speak for uh
exactly what the prime minister knew but
my sense is that he would have been
aware when uh the wire was tripped into
formal disciplinary action or let alone
a formal sanction um but of course we're
constantly i mean
westminster is awash with gossip rumor
and i think it is right to draw that
what
2019 when you had to let's say
discipline him you say talk to him he
wasn't disappearing action it's very
important to draw that so when you had
to speak to him firmly did you then
subsequently tell the prime minister
about it no and i wouldn't expect to in
relation to something that fell below
the bar of disciplinary action what i
did do was inform the chief whip because
i do think it's important that we keep a
proper record and i referred it to the
cabinet office propriety and ethics team
because i wanted the assurance and
that's not to say that i disagreed with
the view of the permanent secretary or
the civil service but because i attached
such importance to those around and
those who work with us having the
confidence in the processes which are
there to protect them it's very
important and i take that incredibly
seriously the fda and prospect unions
they represent about a thousand
parliamentary workers
they say that parliament is an unsafe
place
to work because potentially of people
like this
well that's why we've got the new
processes in place uh an independent
grievance and complaint process and we
need to vest them with the power and the
confidence to do their job in the
relation to chris pincher that's exactly
what's happening okay um
talk to me about what should happen to
him now well i think if you've got an
independent process
it's right to allow them to conduct
their investigation and then depends on
the outcome and i'm not going to get
ahead of that
he's an auditory mp he's had the whip
removed suspended pending that
investigation that's the right thing i
do also think when you've got a formal
mechanism like this you've got to
respect and not impinge on its ability
to conduct that investigation without
prejudice without prejudice when you
look back what would you have done
differently i'm doing exactly the same
again
even though it appears
from this list that i've read to you i
don't need to go into all of the details
not least because their children are
watching at this time in the morning but
back from
2012 through to 2022 that's a 10-year
period where it looks as though um he
has potentially abused several people
on varying levels and that's the luxury
i was going to go on to no i was going
to go on to say
given that should the police be
investigating
well look you asked me what i could have
done should have done differently
i i think it's critically important to
have an independent process once the
civil service conducted i wanted the
reassurance of the cabinet office but
there was nothing that was reported back
to me that would have warranted
disciplinary action let alone a police
investigation of course
if i'd have known something different a
different set of facts i would have
acted on them as quickly and as
rigorously as i did the complaint that i
became aware of okay it's good to talk
to you just gotta leave it there thanks
very much indeed thank you
uh well let's uh have a look at our top
stories for you this morning deputy
prime minister there dominic rob telling
this program that boris johnson was not
aware of any substantial formal
complaints against his former deputy
chief whip but did know of allegations
of misconduct
six people have been killed and dozens
injured in a mass shooting in an
independence day parade in chicago a 22
year old man has been arrested
and a premier league footballer is
arrested in london on suspicion of rape
[Music]
tamara's here morning morning kate i'm
more confused now than i was before i
know well it now emerges that when chris
pincher was a minister at the foreign
office under the early part of boris
johnson's government there was a
complaint made about him by someone who
worked with him and that triggered
formal disciplinary action the deputy
prime minister admitted that he was
involved that he spoke to mr pincher who
he claims he found to be an exceptional
and very professional minister and said
to him that this must not ever be
repeated and that it seems was that he
says the victim alleged victim did not
want to take it further into formal
disciplinary proceedings but he referred
it to the cabinet office who would have
been aware of it so when the prime
minister was carrying out his reshuffle
the beginning of this year the cabinet
office apparently he's number 10 keeps
saying the cabinet office did not raise
any objections to his appointment well
they would have known about that
did the prime minister didn't tell the
prime minister though he said he didn't
tell the prime minister at the time
because there was no disciplinary
process so he said it wouldn't have
tripped the wire of that level of
scrutiny but he has discussed he said
this matter with the prime minister over
the past few days so perhaps that starts
to account for some of these lines
coming out of number 10 saying we
weren't aware of any serious specific
allegation perhaps serious allegation
means something that triggered formal
disciplinary proceedings but certainly
concerns were raised about mr pinter's
behavior and the the deputy prime
minister was aware of them
uh what does that leave us from what
will quince said yesterday when he was
sat there to what downing street are
telling us today well downing street
insists that they are being consistent
because they have said the prime
minister wasn't aware of serious
specific allegations ongoing at the time
but they were really contorting
themselves yesterday there was a
briefing by the prime minister's
spokesperson regular lobby briefing to
political journalists in which he
conceded that there were unsubstantiated
allegations and then said that all the
allegations flying around about mr
pincher had been resolved so anything
that had been raised had been dealt with
so for example the story that was in the
mail on sunday five years ago about
mr pincher making advances towards a
former olympic grower and conservative
activist and that was looked at no
further action was taken so they say
everything they knew about was resolved
there was nothing ongoing but this does
continue to raise questions about the
prime minister's judgment in knowing
that there were rumors and allegations
flying around and uh choosing to to
ignore those okay um thanks very much
tom uh tomorrow's take at ten no ten
o'clock nine o'clock this morning unless
you want to stay on for another hour
love to okay thanks a lot uh ukraine's
president vladimir zelinski has called
for colossal funds for his country's
recovery and has said the nation's
forces wouldn't give up the ukrainian mp
lesia vasilenko joining us now hello gee
thanks for joining us on the programme
this morning um
is what is russia
winning this war at the moment
i wouldn't say so uh russia is trying to
win this war and they're trying to win
it was the same methods they have used
in 2014
uh whereby by uh pushing the world into
a protracted conflict and tiring out
both ukraine and the west they are
trying to legitimize the land grabs uh
which which they control today and today
that's 20 percent of ukraine's territory
but the fight is ongoing definitely and
the fight will be ongoing for as long as
ukraine gets the support the military
support and of course the financial
support necessary to fight back russia
which still remains one of the top five
largest armies in the world although it
does look as though ukraine has at least
now lost control of the luhansk region
what does that mean for you
uh that's uh one of the eastern
industrial regions
of ukraine uh it's
it was the principal industrial artery
of ukraine
today russia holds control over that
region uh just on 23rd february they
held a little less than a third of
control over that region so of course uh
you are right referring to your first
question that russia is making advances
in ukraine and they will continue making
them until and unless they are stopped
and the only way to stop them today is
of course through uh military uh
military pushback under fierce a much
more fierce military pushback than we
are having today
uh you are asking the un to
force moscow to force russia to pay
reparations for the damage done to your
country um why do you think that
even if the un said that that should
happen that russia moscow would abide by
that
uh that's up to
the international community to unite
efforts and to push moscow to abide by
that because of course
there's
no way that putin will one day wake up
and say oh yes i did wrong let me pay
out all the reparations no that's that's
never going to happen and that has never
happened in the history of the world
where a wrongdoer would just uh
just repent and just pay up for the
wrongdoings that that have been
committed now but it is up to us as an
international community as a
modern democratic society to administer
justice according to the procedures
which are already in place within the un
framework within the uh framework of the
international criminal court
and of a possible tribunal which must be
set up
on the aggression of russian federation
against ukraine because that will be how
the societies of the future will will
look back in history we'll look back on
our society and that is how they will
judge us and it's not
you know justice it's not so much about
the one who is being judged it's about
those who are doing the judging and who
are administering justice to the to the
victims of the crimes that have been
committed by the wrongdoer and this term
a case the russian federation
how's morale with the military personnel
uh the army the ukrainian army is as
determined as ever to fight back there
have been losses in the ukrainian army
uh these losses have been big there are
there are huge numbers of prisoners of
war at the moment and that gives the
resolve to the ukrainian military to the
men and women alike who are fighting for
ukraine to fight back harder to
avenge the lives that have been lost and
to get
back to
uh their comrades their uh
you know
uh
the members of their military units who
have been taken prisoners of war
um i believe that the ukrainian flag has
now been raised on snake island for the
first time since the start of the war
what will that have done what did that
do for um morale
that's uh that's a huge uh
morale boost boosting exercise but not
only it's also uh that island is also a
sort of strategic uh strategic point for
ukraine uh
that island has actually been uh a
subject of many international disputes
over the years
and uh
it's uh there are allegedly there are um
energy resources around that island so
that's that's an important point in that
term uh but for the morale of the
military as you are asking for them to
regain territory and to set up flag at
uh
one of the first
one of the first
lands that have been occupied by russia
since uh february 24th that's that's a
huge boost and uh i am extremely proud
of the ukrainian military who have uh
been doing the fighting day in day out
and who have finally managed to set up
that flag and to to see it fly high and
proud of the on the snake island
um officials uh russian officials in the
city of belgarrod
say that ukraine has
deliberately targeted dozens of
residential buildings several people
killed as a result i mean if that were
to be the case and to be investigated
that would be a war crime is that
something that you recognize
not as far as i'm aware of unless we
receive other data from
i don't know intelligence or whatever um
there's there's no
science saying that ukraine has been
targeting inside of russia
so there have been no missiles being
fired from ukraine into russia
not to my awareness
okay where are we as far as president
zielenski is concerned he continues with
his nightly address to the ukrainian
people it must be incredibly difficult
to try to continue
to
convince the people of ukraine that this
is a war that you can win while also
trying to convince the west that you
need more
more military arsenal
president zlensky has been since day one
since the 21st of february this rupert
this uh
promoter of ukraine inside ukraine and
outside and this is exactly the kind of
tactics that uh
can work against russia's plan to to
wage a war of attrition meaning a war
that will
that is targeting uh
the enemy by tiring out the enemy in
this case being not just ukraine but
also being the western powers and
president zolensky is doing
the the the best countering tactic there
is he is um
inspiring the ukrainian population
and he is also inspiring western leaders
to do more for ukraine this is the only
thing that uh that can
outplay putin by having the world and
ukraine united and by having a complete
100
determination that ukraine will be
furnished with everything it needs to
win this war from weapons for our
military training from uh everything uh
every kind of sanction needed to weaken
russia and i think this is this is key
the unity behind ukraine and inside
ukraine is key in winning over putin
um it's good to talk to you thank you so
much for taking the time to join us on
the programme this morning much
appreciated thank you
travel chaos again at we're being told
of today
resignations yesterday most flights
being cancelled today let's get the
latest with simon calder he's travel
editor of the independent standing by at
gatwick for us this morning um
oh you're at heathrow forgive me um talk
to me simon about um
what's going on with british airways
what's going on with easyjet what does
it mean for people who want to travel
with their kids this summer
well the story of the summer k is really
set out here at beautiful um uh heathrow
fantastic morning uh hundreds of people
flights getting away absolutely as
normal but not as many as there might be
british airways so first up they've
cancelled again slightly over 100
flights a day uh that's basically due to
a shortage of resources but crucially
they have not been cancelling them at
the very last minute uh yes there's been
overnight delays and so on the hotel
where i'm uh currently adjacent to uh is
absolutely full last night because of
various problems during the uh
evening however most people are getting
away and we are going to see on british
airways a couple of developments this
week first of all uh we're going to see
yet more cancellations for the summer uh
that will be because if they can give up
uh some of their flying this summer
they've already cut one in nine flights
if they give up even more to keep keep
the operation kind of in going sensibly
for the rest of them they won't lose
their slot but the other
thing hanging over their heads is 700
staff passenger service agents working
here at terminal 3 and also at terminal
5 at heathrow voted overwhelmingly to
strike i'm hearing words but i've not
got anything official from the gmb or
the unite unions that we might get
strike dates announced today they have
to give at least two weeks warning
bearing in mind that the busiest days of
this year are going to be the 22nd of
july that's the friday and the following
friday the 29th of july so that's
british airways kind of keeping going um
should i go on to easyjet
uh yeah but before that i want to know
about whether um if you've got travel
insurance you get covered
uh sure yeah and look um which have done
a big survey this morning saying that um
a lot of travel insurance policies don't
cover you if your flight is affected by
strikes and talking of strikes by the
way you're not going to see departures
from here to copenhagen to oslo to
stavanger in norway on sas because their
pilots
went on strike yesterday afternoon
however that is a concern but for the
vast majority of people as you and i
have talked before okay um insurance
isn't kind of really relevant you should
get your holiday and that's the message
that um has to be put across if your
flight is cancelled the airline has to
get you to your destination by hook or
by crook and that includes spending an
awful lot of money buying you a seat on
a rival airline so uh yes unsettling but
i think uh kind of
on the scale of the problems uh not too
much of an issue okay um just very
quickly if you would uh on easyjet as
you were saying
yeah just imagine england lose their
first group match at the world cup
gareth southgate loses leaves and um
they're left behind that's not quite
what happened yesterday but piece of
value he is the chief
chief operating officer of easyjet
generally well regarded in his previous
jobs at laser airlines and ryanair um he
uh
resigned or perhaps was resigned
yesterday um there has been an awful lot
of unhappiness particularly among uh
pilots and cabin crew
but effectively here we are at the start
of the absolute peak month of july and
august and one of their top men has left
meanwhile east yet continue to cancel
mostly a few days in advance and if
you're flying in and out of gatwick
that's the main problem however 1700
flights across europe on easyjet will
get ahead go away as normal
okay thanks very much thank you simon
right just a minute ago sat here was the
deputy prime minister former foreign
secretary telling me that the prime
minister he didn't think that he knew
anything about what was going on with
this picture chap back in 2019 tamara's
here well we have just seen a letter
from the person who was the senior civil
servant at the foreign office the
permanent secretary simon mcdonald at
the time that we now know a complaint
was made against chris pinchot in 2019
yeah which uh mr rob was just telling us
about he said he knew about it he dealt
with it but he only informed the prime
minister in the last few days simon
mcdonald who was the permanent secretary
the senior civil servant of the foreign
office says that number 10 have not been
telling the truth about this he said
that when um
a couple of days ago the um number 10
was saying that no official complaint
against against chris pincher were made
he claims they were fully aware that
when he was a minister
at the foreign office there were
complaints made by officials about chris
pincher's behavior
an investigation into those upheld the
complaint which he says was of a similar
nature to those reported last week at
the carlton club i.e a groping alleged
groping offense
they he says that the number 10 were not
being accurate because mr johnson was
briefed in person about the initiation
and the outcome of that investigation
and that chris pincher was not
exonerated so he's saying that boris
johnson knew all of this so to
characterize the allegations as
unsubstantiated is therefore wrong
and he is writing to the parliamentary
commissioner for standards asking for an
investigation into all of this uh
because he says that uh in inaccurate
complaints by downing street continue to
be repeated uh in the media and he says
that he's conscious of the duty owed to
the person who made the complaint but
this is his duty towards the victims he
said mr pincher deceived me and others
in 2019 he cannot be allowed to use the
confidentiality of the process three
years ago to pursue what he calls his
predatory behavior in other contexts
this is the killer path for me um just
um analyzing this for me if you would
given what we just heard from dominick
rams saying that the prime minister was
only told by him about it just a few
days ago and it was an incident that
happened in 2019 where he uh hold him
over the coals about it but it didn't go
any further mr johnson was briefed in
person about the
initiation and outcome of the
investigation there was a formal
complaint allegations were resolved only
in the sense that the investigation was
completed mr pincher was not exonerated
to characterize the allegations as
unsubstantiated is therefore
wrong yeah he's accusing number 10 of
lying when he said that there were no
formal allegations no formal complaints
raised what number tanner said the whole
time is yes there may have been rumors
and unsubstantiated allegations but the
prime minister didn't know of anything
concrete that slightly changed yesterday
when they say that anything he knew
about had already been resolved but the
permanent secretary he was there when
this complaint was made about a minister
says the prime minister knew all about
it he knew that the investigation had
been launched so we knew a formal
complaint had been made he also knew
what the outcome was which is that they
said he had not been exonerated they
found he had done what he was accused of
doing but as you heard dominic rob
saying there he had a talking to and
then continued in his job so the prime
minister was fully aware of this the
whole time and yet decided to appoint
him to the very serious job of being
deputy chief whip in charge of
discipline for the whole party in
february of this year knowing all about
the fact that someone had made a
complaint about inappropriate behavior
and he had been upheld would the foreign
secretary have known that the permanent
secretary had spoken to the prime
minister
well dominic robb was clear that he'd
briefed the prime minister about it in
the last few days
and he he said that the prime minister
may have known about it before but that
he may have only known when when the
disciplinary procedure began but
certainly the senior civil servant at
the foreign office says he was fully
aware of the fact that it was happening
and the outcome so we're number 10 say
they weren't aware of any formal
complaints he said that's incorrect and
he now wants it investigated okay
tomorrow oh goodness me what a can of
worms we'll talk to you uh in the next
hour thanks very much indeed let's uh
change pace for neither should we and
one family lobbying to bring the cancer
vaccine that saved their son liam's life
to the uk
um three years ago liam was diagnosed
with neuroblastoma a rare type of cancer
now three years later after his family
raised money to take him to new york for
an experimental vaccine he is
cancer-free i'm pleased to say that they
are all joining us
now there he is dressed for school hello
everybody
hi
hello hello so that's kylie that's liam
and then claire and mike um hello to you
all um claire mike tell us liam's story
well liam was diagnosed with
neuroblastoma cancer a day after kylie
was born
so i've just given birth to kylie and
the day after we received the
worst news that a family could ever
imagine our world shattered and
liam started chemotherapy that day um he
only had a 40 chance of survival and
we went in adrenaline mode and
he had very aggressive frontline
treatments and it was during frontline
treatments where i discovered a vaccine
that was only available in america that
could potentially save his life and i
knew then that we had to have this
vaccine for liam without a doubt the
only problem was it cost around a
quarter of a million pounds and we were
on a deadline we had to start
fundraising immediately
and lockdown happened
so we we were in turmoil
but we met the most amazing family and
we appealed to the hearts of the general
public and the
the people of kent um and the world were
incredible they came together to
essentially save liam's life and we
managed to
come up with the money
and
off we went to america during lockdown
with all the rules and regulations um
and um he received the treatment and um
a year
in new york um was traveling near and
back he now is doing so well
he's got so much energy and we are
campaigning now to get the vaccine
available in the uk
and dad you have been speaking to the
health secretary here in the uk haven't
you to try to make sure that that
vaccine is available for other families
as well how have you got on with that
i know that's um that's all my wife um
she's she she's uh she's the one that's
been doing all this fantastic work in
terms of trying to bring this treatment
here to the uk
she's been meeting with
her local mp who arranged the meeting
with sachi java to discuss bringing this
treatment here
to the uk so that families don't have to
go through
what we had to go through because
you know there's potentially up to 50
families a year
that are looking to try and get their
children over to the us to have this
treatment which is extremely expensive
so my wife has been on a massive drive
to to create awareness um within the
government and to to push to get this
treatment made available here
sure when i say you of course i mean you
as a family not just not just you dad um
mom how does this vaccine work
so it's um it works on the immune system
um so the vaccine is um
it it
it works on the immune system and that's
um it helps the
the body
recognize the cells uh that are that are
causing the cancer and then um it makes
cells to to
fight the cancer cells
so um it's been proven to work um
and
all that evidence is in the the us
so at the moment we're trying to get the
vaccine trial set up here
as soon as possible and we've had
quite a few meetings and i'm hopefully
uh
well i'm hoping to meet with uh sajid
javid uh very soon
fantastic well we know he watches the
program so hopefully he'll move that up
in your diary a little bit listening to
what you have to say this morning now
dad how how's liam doing now does he
want to talk to us or is he a little bit
shy
he's definitely not shy he's going to be
but he's doing fantastic he's got tons
of energy yeah what would you like to
say
well
he was telling me he wants to go to the
moon this morning
what's your favorite subject at school
liam
what's your favorite subject
math
maths always show off when my little boy
when i used to ask some other people i
used to say lunch do you like lunch as
well
yes i like lunch ah yeah
don't we all and how do you get on with
your sister do you play really well
together
yes we we make our pillows look like it
okay okay um and what about your do you
look after your little sister
yes
do you if i asked her what would she say
um do they
i don't know does carly want to chat to
us i'm not sure kylie hello good morning
let's talk do you want to say hello it
was your birthday yesterday
many happy returns did you get fabulous
things oh she's a bit shy she's a bit
shy um it's so lovely though isn't it
mum dad to be you know two years ago you
wouldn't have thought that you would
have been in this position would you no
absolutely nice and
we are so delighted and we want to make
a difference and if we can
help by bringing this vaccine
into the country in any way um we will
be achieving a lifetime goal and
and liam is our
our star and i believe he actually wants
to be a rock star he told me this
morning
[Music]
maybe he can be a rock star a rock star
going to the moon
i think elton john already did that in
in his lyrics anyway
it's good to talk to all of you i don't
know if
the kids want to wave goodbye and say
thank you to everybody that helped raise
money for them bye
thank you to everyone yeah bye bye
thanks so much for joining us really
appreciate it bye everyone take care bye
bye bye we'll see you in just a second
here on skype
[Music]